c'est un débat vieux comme le monde que
vient de relancer la première dame de
france brigitte mâcon qui accuse des
jeux vidéo d'être trop violent et
addictif pour les plus jeunes lors d'un
passage à la maison des adolescents de
la ville de blois
la première dame a déploré l'addiction
aux jeux vidéo des joueurs qui en force
seraient au nombre de 37 millions
brigitte macron c'est surtout attaqué à
fortnight jeu de combat particulièrement
populaire chez des jeunes dans le monde
plus de 350 millions de joueurs ont été
recensés fortnight c'est terrible quand
ils sont sur des jeux comme ça comment
faire pour qu'ils arrêtent
selon le ms seulement 2 à 3 % des
joueurs seraient compulsif et leur
addiction pourrait alors s'apparentait à
une maladie mentale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les jeux vidéo sont ils trop
dangereux pour nos enfants
sophie très juste après doit-on rouvrir
au risque de sacrifier des personnes
gyan reviendra sur cette remarque de gan
wax qui sera avec nous il sera en face
le docteur jean paul hamon pour le
moment on est avec un animateur que
j'adore gamer sur game one et il est sur
fun également c'est julien tellouck que
j'adore il est excellent on vous jure
que c'est vrai pour le regarder il est
très très bon julien gros talons merci
merci beaucoup et ça me gêne
samedi l abc il ira défendre bien sûr il
va défendre les les jeux vidéo et on à
jacques cheminade alors c'est un honneur
pour nous de vous avoir jacques
cheminade homme politique bien sûr
partie solidarité progrès qui veut
interdire les jeux vidéo ultraviolents
merci d'être là
j'admire chez vous alors ben je voulais
déjà je vous laisser la parole alors
suite à ce qu'a dit brigitte mâcon vous
vous êtes d'accord avec elle vous
trouvez qu'il faut interdire ces jeux
comme fort night qui sont n'ont pas
fourni est d'accord world of warcraft
d'accord ou manhunt ou de jeu de cette
nature là elle vous connaissez
école est rien et donc non c'est ce qui
est assez fort inspiré massacre en vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce serait cesser
cela on enlève ces jeux là très violent
qu'est ce que c'est il a dit il a dit
lui-même il a dit lui-même il a dit
aussi il ya ce contexte là mais david
grossman qui est l'expert des jeux vidéo
qui était auparavant celui qui a
organisé pour la mère américaine
la désinhibition de la capacité tué les
soldats américains ne tuez pas ils
tueront pas tués dans la guerre cession
ni la première 1 mondiale est la
deuxième guerre mondiale seulement 15 %
tiré pour tuer donc fallu que tout le
monde put alors on a fait des vidéos
pour gagner ça grossman disait ça
justifiait romaine militaire maintenant
on va le faire dans le civil et ils ont
fait les jeux vidéo ultraviolents avec
des scènes de tortures des saintes de
najaf où la dignité de la personne
humaine c'est ça le vrai problème alors
à le jeu vidéo en soit c'est ça et ça
lui-même le dit la violence n'est pas
amusante la violence n'est pas un jeu la
violence parce que tu y as dur la pousse
à bout il ya des enfants de plus en plus
jeunes qui jouent à ces jeux qui sont
ses vrais mine de rien et on le voit
c'est voilà dans la foi voilà j'étais
chez mon ami boulounencs j'avais amené
mon fils avec moi il le fait jouer à un
jeu vidéo et je vois un moment mon fils
avec un sabre voilà en train de tuer des
gens sur un jeu vidéo italie c'est vrai
que je me suis dit bon voilà c'est des
jeux de rien ça peut ça peut choquer
c'est vrai que ça peut donner des
mauvais exemple en plus aujourd'hui les
jeux ils sont fait d'une telle manière
il ya une telle qu'elle est tellement
bien fait c'est tellement réel tellement
réaliste que ça fait vraiment flipper on
a vraiment l'impression que c'est une
vraie image et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est compliqué allez on va ouvrir le
débat que c'est le quart d'heure son
fils de suite puisque je voulais
l'introduction de jacques cheminade sim
partie jingle
et à julien tellouck gamer animateurs
qui lui il comprend pas ça j'ai du mal à
en temps de voir jacques cheminade j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous mais là on
est en train de faire un faux débat
puisqu'à la base à l'ap a décidé de
vendre la part prêt à paroles pour
interdire les jeux vidéo il ya eu un
quiproquo en donne elle a pris la parole
en envoyant un spectacle d'ado est là
dit elle à ce moment là ouais fortnight
et tout ça riblon et par la suite c'est
les médias notamment télé 7 jours et
femme actuelle qui auront encore monté
ça en épingle et diaboliser le jeu vidéo
parce que le jeu vidéo on le diabolise
toujours et ça malheureusement passé des
punchline des années 90 tout a changé
depuis
donc quand vous parlez de violence dans
les jeux vidéo il ya eu lieu de guerre
il ya des jeux de gangsters au même
titre que le cinéma ou les séries télé
et là c'est le rôle des parents de
regarder les recommandations à la vente
donc cyril à siwel vous lécher mouloud
fallait regarder la reconversion la
vente du zéro qui a des recommandations
minard c'est vraiment par exemple
fortnight c'est recommandé au coût de 12
ans ouais si vous avez mourier nous en
faut pas jouer alors c'est les parents
qui doublera parce que moi je connais
plein de jeunes pleins de moins de 12
ans qui joue à forte night bac c'est à
dire que ça veut dire quelque part on
joue même un réseau entre eux tout ce à
quoi les parents ils doivent faire leur
rôle de parents ils doivent tout
vérifier les temps d'écran le talent
mais j'ai coincé et s en est pris plein
la gueule sur les réseaux sociaux à
cause de ça ouais mais réduite et il a
raison le monsieur là vous avez raison
merci oui c'est bien tu es locaux et
julia je regagne la raison c'est loin
d'être une déclaration de guerre
viennent au contraire c'est une simple
réaction qu'elle a eu
suite à une saynète qui a eu dans cette
maison des ados où ce sont les jeunes
notamment une jeune fille s'appelle
coralie parce que c'était un cours de
théâtre dans cette maison des ados qui
financées par les pièces jaunes et c'est
le titre coralie qui a parlé de forte
taille c'est tout mais c'est pas du tout
une déclaration de guerre loin de là
alors une fois je voudrais dit selon ces
études et ça leur déclaration contre ce
concret comme état d'esprit quand on
exhibe la violence une violence qui
dégrade la personne humaine on parle pas
de violence l'ajac là on parle de voile
à passer par l'apparition à dealer faire
décrocher il n'ya pas d'addiction
d'ailleurs on parle juste de pratiquants
excessive et jérôme a donné des chiffres
eux selon une étude belge récente les
jeux vidéo sera à l'origine de nombreux
problèmes physiques chez les adolescents
cette enquête montrerait que six jeunes
sur dix souffrirait de troubles
physiques tels que des ressentis au
niveau des yeux au coup à la nuque à la
tête au pouce et au bras je vous dis la
vérité moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti
voit jouer beaucoup
il va déjà que j'avais un toit plat pour
rien et j'avais et c'est vrai que ça et
mine de rien julien de quoi quand tu
joues longtemps dans les mêmes temps
balles à la tête a les yeux un peu afin
qu'il faut faire il faut pas jouer dix
heures d'affilée c'est sûr elle souffre
à rester devant la télé pendant dix
heures d'affilée
si j oui le propre de chaque génération
ses de s'indigner de ce que fait la
génération d'après en disant moi quand
j'étais gamin je m'abrite si c'est pas
devant les jeux vidéo via les jeux vidéo
c'est pas abrutissant c'est une vraie
culture ça stimule l'intelligence la
créativité
moi je ne suis pas voilà les jeunes je
pense qu'ils sont pas bêtes ils
comprennent bien que quand ils utilisent
un un sabre c'est pour de faux et font
qu'aujourd'hui pardon mais alors du
confinement alors du coc vide où les
jeunes n'ont plus d'interactions
sociales balles et les jeux vidéo ça
reste un moyen de garder l'interaction
sociale à distance avec l'un d'eux - moi
c'est un jeu en ligne
c'est un moment des ventes de 5 je veux
faire mon ski moi ce soir en rentrant je
vous dis tout de suite je vous jure que
c'est vrai échange sur fifa et qu'on
fasse dressé sur wii jacques un danger
c'est pas devenir quelqu'un qui reste en
état d'actions chez lui et c'est les
hikikomori au japon 20 % et jean de
japonais mal d'ailleurs un autre raison
plus jolie ou qu'ils restent chez eux
qui sortent plus dont concrètes à des
conférences ou légendes partial
attendait en ce moment c'est à dire les
jeunes les pauvres c'est horrible ce qui
leur arrive en ce moment regarder un
petit peu ils peuvent aller au cinéma
avec son lot il a prouvé ce jeu vidéo si
les gens ne voient plus rien au film
c'est sûr sur la violence jacques au
niveau de la violence dans les jeux
vidéo ont dit tout le temps ça rend
violent tous à vous alors déjà là quand
on joue un jeu de guerre on va refaire
par exemple la première guerre mondiale
où la deuxième guerre mondiale
ça c'est pour un public adulte bien sûr
on a 11 ans on va pas jouer à ce genre
de jeu mais moi à jacques ça fait des
années que je joue à mario depuis que
j'ai 7 ans je joue à mario j'ai jamais
eu la moustache et j'aimerais porter une
salopette et j'avais été plombier
alors je vous dirais les gamer 36,5
millions de gamers occasionnels en
france on en fait partie
voilà on va pas se mentir 53% des gamers
sont des hommes et 47 % des femmes
l'âge moyen des gamer je vous le dis il
élevé 39 ans et pan qui jouissent à
tignes alors moi j'ai été gameuse
pendant longtemps déjà toute mon enfance
j'ai jouer à minecraft a énormément
gâcher way est en fait ce qui est
dangereux c'est vraiment la diction mais
comme n'importe que par leur creux comme
n'importe quel addiction donc c'est à
dire le cannabis la clope l'alcool etc
et aussi je veux te dire que cette
addiction reconnu comme une maladie
mentale qui concerne selon l oms de la 3
% des joueurs ce qui est nous aimer
attendent un rapport à tout le monde
attention cependant les premiers juges
allemands l'ont msa a recommandé aux
jeunes de jouer aux jeux vidéo il ya
toute la population parce que ça
maintenant les lien social c'est vrai
que s'évader mais c'était vrai ça
jacques cheminade c'est vrai que l'om
est alors recommandé de jouer aux jeux
vidéo il ya interdiction labour non mais
c'est bien mais ça me choque pas ce qui
me choque
vous jouez vous je jouais oui à ce choc
ben assassin's creed et j'ai donné non
mais c'est pas suffisant for abba oui
c'est mieux j'étais au paris-sg game
show a bien sûr mais moi ce qui me
choque c'est une côte est ce que jenny
cette violence exhibé avec les limites
de plus en plus grande si je suis
d'accord mais mais c'est aussi la pompe
à fric
bah oui c'est sûr crush n'ai pas envie
que le prévenu en assurerait en mettant
de l'avic sion oui ou alors mais lui un
peu plus haut on peut rien dire avec
vous et ne peut pas dire que ça va mal
on va dire que c'est la pompe à fric
aussi pour le cinéma c'est la pompe à
huile
la société de l'après derrière morgan
moi vraiment je rejoins guillaume qui
disait par rapport au fait de la
violence c'est vraiment la consommation
qu'il faut généralement je suis pas
maman j'ai encore le temps
mais bon c'est vraiment ça et souvent
les parents se pose vraiment des
questions par rapport aux jeunes je
connais des mamans que les gamins de 13
14 jusqu'à ses 17 ans c'est vrai que
certains sont vraiment cloîtrés dans
leur chambre ils parlent de leurs amis
en mode joue avec mes amis mais quelle
famille mes amis gamers non c'est
vraiment la consommation qu'il faut
gérer moi j'ai joué toute mon enfance je
vois quoi mario aladin je me souviens
des codes donc la mémoire et travailler
dans un jeu vidéo
si tu veux aller hop et du génie dans
aladdin ces génies jafar aladin à bouffe
le code soit je m'en rappelle non
vraiment les jeux vidéo font travailler
la mémoire la découverte l'esprit mais
c'est vrai l'équipe a dit d'abord fait
ça renforce en tout cas les réflexes a
été prouvé scientifiquement moi je vis
depuis 16 ans avec un gamer qui joue
tout le temps et je peux vous assurer
que les plus gros fous rires qui là
c'est quand ils jouent pourquoi parce
qu'il ya une révolution que je trouve
formidable
il joue en live donc maintenant il garde
un lien social il peut jouer avec des
personnes qui sont en israël
il joue avec il parle non seulement avec
ses cousins qui sont en israël avec tout
le monde tout en restant sur son canapé
et tout en jouant aussi gérer la
pression ce que dit jacques et je pense
complètement linverse de vous c'est à
dire que les jeux vidéo ça permet aux
jeunes d'être rapide dans un monde qui
va de plus en plus vite de maîtriser la
technologie d'apprendre à gagner à
perdre de se battre c'est jérémie
labelle morini-bosc elle jouer à pacman
encore hier
maintenant c'est génial la vidéo que
j'achète pour tout le monde donc je
regarde vous persie mer mais trois gars
et magali bertaud je suis maman excusez
moi j'ai une ado à la maison et ça me
gêne vraiment d'être enfermé dans une
chambre et je trouve au contraire que sa
coupe de l'extérieur mais c'est au beau
gosse les jeux vidéo de maintenant ne
sont pas les mêmes vous parlez tous des
jeux vidéo d'il ya dix ans mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus les maintenant
dans les maisons sur pas toujours mario
il ya toujours neuf / dg de guerre toute
la journée entre et je suis désolé
bonjour à ses rôles il ya un vrai
problème des locations en fait c'est le
rôle des parents de surveiller mais
j'aimerais attendre des battants d'écran
c'est tous les écrans c'est valable pour
les réseaux sociaux parce qu'on parle de
violence mais sur internet et des vidéos
violentes
il ya personne qui protège des enfants
de ça c'est pareil sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est de la violence non-stop
sur les réseaux sociaux
je leur fais je les parents ils doivent
ils doivent vraiment surveiller ça
regardez contrôle parental à l'intérieur
des consoles c'est sur la switch live à
la playstation
et là vous pouvez limiter le temps des
ces salles aux offres de jeux et c'est
50 50 et 55 en scène brillante et fanny
par l'abbé le monde entier et white
parle jamais et alors je dis on s'en
fout
jt oui c'est une choc c'est quand
activision-blizzard qui fait call of
duty
ce qui me fait mal c'est quoi cette
finance qui met la main sur ces trucs là
norme et qu'il utilise et jeu est dans
une vision s'était habitué à faire un
podium d'un gant sa femme est en tout
cas jacques cheminade
vous avez beau si non sans rigoler lui
qu'il est à la maison on fais ce que tu
veux
on joue toute la journée tu avais pas
attention d'accord